yesterday was the ninth anniversary of
the lynching of a police officer named
Darren Wilson on the morning of August 9
2014 Wilson tried to detain 18-year-old
Michael Brown who had just robbed a
convenience store and attacked the store
clerk and that's when according to the
Obama doj quote Wilson and other
Witnesses stated that brown reached into
Wilson's SUV through the open driver's
window and punched and grabbed Wilson
investigators made the Discrimination by
observing quote bruising on Wilson's jaw
and scratches on his neck the presence
of Brown's DNA and Wilson's collar shirt
and pants and Wilson's DNA on Brown's
Palm
Brown then tried to grab Wilson's gun
Wilson shot him Brown ran away then
turned around and charged at Wilson and
Wilson fatally shot Brown in
self-defense
now the Obama doj did everything it
could to find some way to charge Darren
Wilson yet those were their conclusions
Wilson did nothing wrong much to the
dismay of those who wish to sacrifice
him on the altar of racial Justice
now despite media reports not a single
witness ever claimed that brown said
don't shoot and all the witnesses who
claimed the Browns hands were in the air
were either contradicted by the evidence
or later recanted their testimony or
both
those are the factual details and if
you're so inclined you can read the full
doj report online and see it all laid
out what you can find online
is what exactly happened to Darren
Wilson
his name is never mentioned in the media
it's as if he never existed the handful
of reports on Wilson in recent years
suggested he's living a life of
anonymity in the middle of nowhere and
that he'll never be able to work as a
police officer again
his life was destroyed
nobody who defamed him as a racist
killer ever apologized nobody who took
part in the destruction of innocent
man's life was ever held accountable for
it
in a country that cared about police
officers or the truth or both that would
be a national Scandal but we don't live
in a country like that so instead
yesterday The Only Name you heard on
this anniversary was Michael Brown they
canonized him all over again here's how
one local news report talked about the
case listen
happening right now a ceremony to honor
Michael Brown he's the teenager shot and
killed by a police officer after a
confrontation the shooting happened nine
years ago today Brown's death sparked
protests in Ferguson and all across the
country this is a live picture from
Canfield Drive where it happened dozens
of people have gathered to remember him
just moments ago they held a moment of
silence for four and a half minutes
representing the four and a half hours
Brown's Body laid on the street after
the shooting the prosecutor later
announced a grand jury had ruled the
shooting was justified charges were
never filed against the officer involved
a ceremony to honor Michael Brown the
teenager shot and killed by a police
officer after a confrontation that's how
a news station quote unquote is talking
about a thug who attacked a store clerk
and then tried to kill a police officer
they don't mention any of those facts
that we just reviewed because they're
inconvenient instead the news station
informs you that Brown's Body laid in
the street for several hours after the
shooting as if that's somehow
incriminating or even relevant of course
they leave out the fact that the mob the
mob that gathered made processing the
crime scene so difficult that Ferguson
had to call in the SWAT team to control
the situation
they don't mention all the lies that the
supposed Witnesses told the media like
the false clan that Michael Brown had
been shot in the back that never
happened
it wasn't just one news station that
decided to lie yesterday about this they
all did it here's how the local Fox
station described what happened listen
welcome back to the 9 A.M today marks
the ninth year since the passing of
Michael Brown Junior and this tragic
incident was sparked uproar not only in
Ferguson but across our nation for
change against police brutality and
Injustice faced by African Americans
again without mentioning any details of
what Michael Brown actually did we're
told this case has something to do with
police brutality and injustices faced by
African Americans
that intro was was followed by a
sympathetic clip with Michael Brown's
family apparently Darren Wilson's family
wasn't available uh maybe they're in
hiding we really don't know
what we could say for sure is that there
weren't any memorial events honoring
Darren Wilson yesterday in St Louis
instead the city put on a series of
events celebrating the legacy of the
thug who robbed stores and attacked a
police officer watch
today marks nine years since the death
of Michael Brown in Ferguson the metro
area is honoring his life today with two
memorial events and our Sydney
Stallworth is live in Clayton with
today's tributes good morning Sydney
good morning Michelle Rennie on August 9
2014 Michael Brown was shot and killed
in the streets of Ferguson following a
confrontation with a Ferguson police
officer now his death sparked outraged
in this community and far beyond leading
to demonstrations and calls for police
reform Nationwide and in just a couple
of hours our community is going to honor
Brown's Life and Legacy now organizers
for these events in his honor are
acknowledging that this painful moment
of our past can hopefully usher in a new
future for our community the first
tribute will be held on Canfield Drive
in Ferguson where Michael Brown was shot
and killed a four and a half minute of
Silence will be held there at 11 15 a.m
to remember the four and a half hours
his body laid in the street
Michael Brown was shot was shot and
killed following a confrontation the
reporter tells us so there's that word
again it was a confrontation
it doesn't imply any kind of fault by
one side or the other doesn't tell you
anything it leaves you completely in the
dark which is the exact opposite of what
the news media is supposed to do
they just want you to know that the
community came together to quote honor
Michael Brown's Life and Legacy they
don't bother explaining
why Brown's Life and Legacy deserves to
be honored
what exactly is his legacy these
so-called reporters they know exactly
what they're doing they're lying on
purpose about something that anybody
with a Google can can uh can prove is is
a lie in about five seconds that's all
it takes
but obviously none of these people can
think for themselves so the question
becomes where are they getting the idea
to do it when it comes to carrying your
valuables or self-defense items in your
vehicle most people feel that they have
to choose between safety or convenience
someone breaking into your car will
typically check the glove box under the
seats the center console well now we can
outsmart them with the headrest safe
which gives you convenience and peace of
mind this is a head rest the header safe
is exactly what it sounds like you can
place your standard headrest in your car
with our easy access safe access safe
you just pull the side part and then you
can either use your fingerprint use a
key or manually type in the code to open
the safe uh and that's it there's all
the stuff in there that you need right
there very very convenient and also
tricky they'll never know the criminals
unless they're watching this ad so let's
hope they don't I don't have a lot of
criminals watching the show that's the
good thing there's no way that anyone
could know that your headrest safe is
even there and even if they did there's
no way they could get it open without
using one of the three methods to unlock
it so the address headrest safe has a
universal design that allows it to fit
all vehicles and the best part is these
come in a variety of colors to make the
interior of your car and match it
perfectly I have their black leather
Vulcan headrest for my vehicle and I
love it I took my family out to dinner
last week and the restaurant only had
valet parking well thanks to my head
rest safe I was able to leave valuables
in my car that I wanted to keep extra
safe depending on the day I'll put
self-defense items cash or medications
in this safe it gives me peace of mind
knowing that it'll stay out of the hands
of our kids valets or Intruders so what
are you waiting for save a hundred
dollars at the headrestsafe.com with
promo code wall should check out that's
the headrestsafe.com promo code Walsh
well we know that the the Obama
Administration benefited from lying
about Michael Brown all the way back in
2014 just as they benefited from lying
about Trayvon Martin and all the other
race hoaxes that's why the Obama doj
investigated Ferguson's police
department and many other police
departments and claim that they must be
racist because they pull over more black
people than white people it didn't
matter to the doj Apparently that
Ferguson is an overwhelmingly black town
which might be the reason why more black
people are pulled over they just ran
with that reasoning because they knew
the city didn't have the money or the pr
resources to fight them in fact
when the city publicly announced that it
disagreed with the Obama doj's
ridiculous reasoning the doj called the
city racist again just for daring to
challenge their narrative so you're
racist and If you deny that you're
racist then well that's just more
evidence that you're racist
it's basically what the doj said and
again that document is online if you
want to read it but still doesn't answer
the question of why now I mean why is
the media still lying now nine years
later about this shooting when everyone
knows they're lying
well it could be that they're still
taking orders from the Democrat Party
which somehow has not given up on this
lie Squad benchwarmer Corey Bush tweeted
yesterday quote today is the ninth
anniversary of Mike Brown's killing he
would be alive today if the institutions
of racism and white supremacy were
eradicated he should be alive today we
will never forget we will continue to
fight for justice and accountability
of course Ben Crump and various
left-wing groups said more or less the
same thing but it's not just a couple of
race hustling lawyers and politicians
from Missouri who are lying about
Michael Brown the Biden administration
at the highest levels is also portraying
Michael Brown as a hero again even now
they're still doing it
this was the state Department's new
Equity representative speaking yesterday
as a Tony blinken looked up listen to
what you said
I would be remiss if I did not
acknowledge that today is also the
anniversary of the killing of Michael
Brown
an unarmed 18 year old black teenager
whose death in Ferguson Missouri sparked
a national outcry
his killing two years after that of 17
year old Trayvon Martin was a pivotal
moment in our country
prompting the need to affirm that black
lives matter
a slogan that has gained Global
resonance not only for people of African
descent
well that's interesting the state
department which uses coordinated
disinformation campaigns to inspire
color revolutions overseas with the
express goal of overthrowing foreign
governments is now deliberately lying
about a police shooting in Ferguson
Missouri from nine years ago they're
telling you that an unarmed black
teenager was just murdered by a cop for
no reason uh nine years after that
narrative was completely and totally
debunked
so why are they doing that
they know exactly how destabilizing that
lie has been over the past decade so
take a look at this chart it shows the
rate of violent crime in Ferguson over
the past few decades and that's the red
line that you can see on the chart it
also shows you how many cases police
have solved in the city over the same
period of time and that's the green line
so you might notice some Trends there
it's kind of hard to miss you see a big
bump in violent crime around 2014 when
the US government decided to pretend
that Michael Brown was a hero while the
number of violent crime cases actually
solved goes drastically in the other
direction
and you can find similar charts from
every major American city uh that there
is I mean in recent years police were
either defunded or scared away
no cop wants to be lynched for doing his
job after all and understandably so
and so predictably cities got much more
dangerous a lot of people died
and it started with the Ferguson lie
which was the Genesis of the modern BLM
movement
now to the left all those deaths were
collateral damage
they think it was all worth it because
the rise of BLM meant more political
power for them
they recruited a mob of enforcers who
could literally set entire communities
on fire with impunity as a message to
the rest of the country they were able
to demonize local police departments
empower the FBI which they controlled
and for the corporations who bankroll
Democrats the rise of BLM was also a
welcome diversion from rising populist
sentiments in both parties
the lying about Ferguson in that sense
Isn't So remarkable the state department
and the Democratic party are pushing for
an internal Revolution here for the same
reason they push for color revolutions
elsewhere
they want to tear down the system of
government that we have in this country
and our rule of law and our Traditions
they want to tear it all down
and they want to replace them with
something very different something uh
equitable as they would say with them in
charge of course
so far their strategy is working we have
to say
and it's a perfect example of how the
left plays the long game
okay they've obtained total narrative
control
now sure their whole narrative was
debunked when it comes to Michael Brown
when it comes to many of these BLM cases
it's a completely debunked but what do
they care they'll just keep repeating
the LIE year after year after year until
eventually the other side gets tired of
correcting it
and then what happens well their version
makes it into the history books
it does make you question how much of
the stuff that you find in history books
can actually be trusted
you know if Corey bush in the state
department and the entire media Democrat
Party can lie about something that we
all remember
what happens when there's nobody left
who remembers it
the unfortunate reality is that
historical lies gain more power and
momentum as time goes on and we move
further away from the event they're
lying about
the truth however doesn't have that kind
of Advantage it doesn't benefit from the
distance
if anything as time goes on
for the truth the road becomes harder
and that is exactly what the left is
counting on
now let's get to our five headlines hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there